they're marked as a house of death and
disease
the barricades a silent reminder to the
village that coronavirus is inside
sarita singh took selfies whilst working
at the local elections in uttar pradesh
she was among hundreds of teachers
ordered by the government to run the
polls
if they refused they risked losing their
jobs
these pictures given to us by teachers
show just how packed it was
by this stage india was already setting
global records for coronavirus
infections
within a week of returning sarita was
ill and struggling to breathe
the teaching union say she was one of
more than 700 teachers in the state who
died from coronavirus
after being ordered to work on the local
elections
uttar pradesh has a population the size
of britain france and germany combined
and has been one of the regions worst
affected by coral virus
but we found little evidence of anything
like lockdown
nearly three-quarters of the population
live in rural
india and this state is traditionally
the heartland of support for the
governing bjp party
but now prime minister narendra modi is
facing criticism at home
and abroad for focusing on the polls and
not the pandemic
we traveled to the village in uttar
pradesh where sarita lived
the teacher's family is not only in
mourning for her but when we arrive
at the home which is now cordoned off
one of her sons who deliberately keeps
his distance
tells us that both his father and
brother have been told they have covered
and the rest of them are all showing
symptoms
we decided to put on some protective
clothing because we're going into a
house where two people are positive
other people are showing symptoms we
want to
protect ourselves but also make sure we
don't take the virus out with us
there's a lot of fear in the village now
the only hospital is nearly two hours
away
and that's if you have a vehicle most
here don't
sarita's family begged her not to do the
election work
but told us the teachers had been warned
they faced being arrested
if they didn't do their civic duty yes
today
all right
foreign
her own mother who's feverish and has a
cough now
is distraught
the family have been waiting nearly a
week for the results of their own covert
tests
and they took sarita to two different
hospitals for help
but couldn't get a test for her straight
away and couldn't get her admitted to
hospital without one
these are the results of the coronavirus
test which she took on may the third
it's positive
she'd suffered seven days of symptoms by
this time and she only got the result
the day after she died so she was never
registered
as a coronavira's death five other
households in the village are now
suffering
the elections here and across the
country have become super spreading
events
taking the virus into areas largely
covered free before
and leaving plenty bitterly doubting the
prime minister's lead role in
campaigning
with such a high human cost alex
crawford sky news in uttar pradesh